there is a wonderful play
called equus and this is a play actually
that my mother
put on in venezuela that's how i first
came
across this play and it's very powerful
story of of a man's descent
into the harrowing realms of despair
within the cracked
psyche it's about a psychiatrist
treating a young man who has blinded
six horses with an ice pick and of
course
immediately we begin the play by being
told that this young man has been
you know arrested and is being taken to
a psychiatrist to try to figure out
what happened this night that he blinded
six horses and
ultimately the play unfolds in a series
of conversations between the
psychiatrist and this
uh tragic tragically sick
young man and you know it it's
absolutely transfixing and engrossing we
come to find out that this young man
grew up in a highly religious
household where we he was largely
repressed his sexuality was
repressed and there's all kind of
bizarre psychosexual dynamics going on
and his relationship with the parents
the point is
this kid grew up sort of robbed of his
capacity to feel
into his own body and in his sexuality
and so as the psychiatrist starts to
sort of undress the the situation and
undress the back
story he comes to realize that this
basically is a story of passion
thwarted right of passion and a feeling
and of compulsion
thwarted or or or repressed so
fundamentally that it has now
uh exploded in a in a destructive
manner which happens so much with people
who have been abused or
or repressed in a significant way um the
point is that we
we get to the end of the play where the
psychiatrist realizes you know he has
hypnotized the kid and the the crime has
been
has been relived the kid has relived the
crime so we as an audience in this
moment now
learn what happened how he sort of had
this psychosexual
uh dynamic with with that he developed
with the horses and then this weird
thing that was mixing religious allegory
and so the horses became stand-ins for
god and the kid wanted to commune
ecstatically with god and so somehow he
engaged in this ritual with the horses
ends up blinding the horses and and in
this
moment of catharsis and revelation
for both the audience and the
psychiatrist the psychiatrist ends the
play
sitting by himself in the dark um
he who himself had been had been in a
state of of kind of brooding nihilism
for the latter part of his career now
has been
has been riveted cracked open by
watching this this kid's experience
unfold and and he realizes now that he
can cure the kid
but he also realizes that to cure the
kid of his pain is to also
cure him or rob him rather of his
passion of his capacity to feel
it's a kind of lobotomy that has to take
place and the psychiatrist knows this
to cure him is also to kill him right to
to cure
him to take away his suffering is to
functionally castrate him
to psychologically castrate him and so
in knowing that the cure um
means the death of this kid's passion
the ferocity of his
feeling the psychiatrist weeps because
he knows that he
he is he is perpetrating a crime
to to to avenge a previous crime and
that's the irony and so
he he knows this lobotomy of the child
must take place and it's a tragic scene
because the psychiatrist himself
cries weeps in that moment i can't
remember
the last line but he basically says i
know what i need to do i know what i
need to do to cure him to cure him is to
kill him to castrate him to rob him of
his passion
and then finally the psychiatrist says
and now here i sit alone in the dark or
something to the degree
of sitting alone in the dark with with
the bankruptcy of what has transpired in
his
and his and and and really the the
the bankruptcy and the tragedy of of of
unhelplessness and hopelessness of this
feeling you know that that
uh you know hints at the corrosive
effects of suffering and how you know
there is really no cure
um ultimately for for for for trauma
without you know killing or
killing a part of somebody as well and
so it's really tragic and the audience
sits there in the dark and it's like
holy [ __ ] you know and it makes you
wonder again
so much of our suffering so much of our
of our excruciating and anguishing
emotional
feelings you know those landscapes of
mind that are dark our shadow the parts
of us that hurt and that ache
um can somehow can sometimes make us you
know unable to adjust
to a to a sick society you know we can't
we can't play within the rails we refuse
to follow the rules we're not adaptable
we're depressed we're anxious and
society wants to cure us but sometimes
to cure us
is to lobotomize us so sure we can be
indented into place we can be socialized
into compliance but you wonder if this
kills the human spirit
and if it doesn't just create a ticking
time bomb that will
you know explosively erupt in some other
horrific context like it does in the
play but i was just thinking about this
because i want
more than anything more than than
nothing you know i want to live
a life of passion i want to live a life
of ferocious emotions but i also
want to be a functional person you know
i want to figure out a way of
of moving about the world with some kind
of equanimity i want to be a responsible
citizen and walking this path walking
this tightrope you know between chaos
and order between passion and
compliance you know requires us to learn
to kind of steer that fire hose somehow
and to tame our our lion and lionesses
that live inside of us but at the same
time we want to roar
we need it to roar and so anyway if
you're not familiar with equus i really
recommend it and uh thanks for listening
to this tirade about um
you know the human condition and
liberating ourselves so that way
we may live passionately um um
and not um not cage ourselves and
repress ourselves to the point of
potentially explosive
nihilism and despair
thanks for listening